I'm just being selfish I just really
love this song I just wanna hear I just
yeah I'm totally gonna record it even
though we're totally recording it um
because I just want the whole thing for
myself because it's that special I
believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show we have my absolute
favorite artist Trevor Hall my friend
Stacy turned me on to his music years
ago and I remember when she asked for it
to be put on and I was listening to
probably country or something like that
and she was like do you mind if I put
some of my music on I was like okay cuz
I'm a little protective of the music and
she put it on and I never turned it off
and Trevor is a fantastic artist he has
a lot of heart a lot of soul he writes
it all himself just has and has a really
cool story I mean like look his dad is a
tennis pro that sells real estate and
when the first time I met him he had a
polo on tucked into his jeans with a
belt like he is like a classic
all-american kind of looking guy and
then there's Trevor who's you know
tattoos and you know definitely much
more laid-back kind of hippie vibe and
he's an artist and he's singing about
spirituality and look I wanted to know
how the hell that guy turns into that
guy like how did that happen in his
family so we talked about that we talked
about travel we talked about how music
impacts him and we talked about personal
growth and how we can expand as human
beings into a space that's not only
better for others but ultimately better
for ourself so please enjoy yeah we were
talking about when I first got here you
know we kind of dipped into like I said
house your parents house and you were
talking about your dad and like I just
think it was so fun that first time I
met you the Cubs win the World Series
okay cuz you go cuz you get on the road
and go or yeah I get it and we like
watch it and like know that it was like
a Mexican kind of restaurant a join to
the little venue in Asheville North
Carolina where it was like it was really
late and there was a rain delay for the
World Series and we all hung out and
watched him win yeah there was a rain
delay
so we're there like all night and then
we drove back to North back to Charlotte
from there from Asheville yeah exactly
we came in and out two other girls came
with me yeah and what I remember
thinking oh yeah it's all good it was so
fun I mean like I just like I you're my
favorite
bye I know completely alanis morissette
is gone it's you now I still have Alanis
but no no I still love Jagged Little
Pill but you know you're I just really
love your music and you know that night
I mean it I'd love the the I kind of
want to talk about the resonance of it
and I like what makes you connect with
the music but first and foremost like
it's super spiritual and it's very deep
and you've traveled to India and you do
have a you you have a story that is not
common but then your dad is there and as
polo tucked into his jeans with a belt
and I'm like wait a second this doesn't
fit not that it has to but I was totally
judging the book by the cover and so
like so you grew up in North Carolina
South Carolina so tell me about like
where you grew up and just like how the
hell you came to this place where you
arrived in India and you're like at
ashrams
okay so he's the hippie thread yep yeah
oh we have all day I mean well until you
have to leave but you know podcast
wouldn't go long so where were you born
then don't worry I got the entire story
wrong about how I started in racing I
interviewed my dad and I was like I was
like so I have my own story and I've
told it for 20 years but you tell me how
he started in racing I was like dad my
story's so much better I'm so
disappointed you just told me that I was
like with the pontoon boat dad I had it
all wrong
yeah I had the whole story wrong I'm
like oh geez
to stick with it you've got the right
story I have sympathy for the situation
[Music]
I use the tennis reel being a realtor
prep school what what was was there a
certain moment where you realize like
I'm different
like I'm seeking something that by
visiting other cultures that hard wood
when people are faced with something
it's they're afraid to show everyone
sometimes the hardest person to show is
your family because they're so close and
they're certain well family it's almost
like the closer the relationship
sometimes the more difficult
conversations can be but they were but
they were supportive so so you told me
wannabe music is that which is that kind
of like the the sort of position you
took on life as like look this is what I
love I don't really want to go to
college or is that is that what was that
the difficult thing or or was that even
a scenario
make sure that I was had full access so
you just learned how to play all of them
[Laughter]
the flute in school and I I kind of
rebelled against I love music and I love
I'm are I would call myself artistic
definitely not a math brain and um and
then I I didn't really want to play
anymore but she had told me why you have
to play I bought your flute I bought it
and so I stopped renting it and I'm like
well okay so I played my flute all the
way in through eighth grade sixth
seventh eighth grade you can always tell
when someone's played the flute because
they go like this when they mimic it and
if they've never played the flute they
go like this you know it goes like this
but people that don't know go like this
yeah yeah which one did you you love the
guitar I'm going to guess what did you
love the most what did you know with
songwriting the flute ran some through
the coal just kind of
okay yeah well just I love the guitar
you stick with that yeah so was
songwriting
I mean songwriting to me like it's a lot
like poetry is that did they feel
similar to you like there's some things
like you know you have dabbled in poetry
right some of that so did you also write
poems or was it just about writing songs
any of the songs feel too private to
share after you'd written them because
they were so and today we're gonna do
that right today well let's talk about
that even just getting your feelings
like you said taking the emotion and
getting getting it through you you know
I feel that in I can feel emotions in a
physical way that I need to either write
it down and get it's like getting it out
somehow it's like and it doesn't make
tangible sense in your mind but the
feelings have an energy and it's about
pulling that out whether it's pulling it
on a paper and writing it down and
getting it out or for me sometimes it's
talking to someone and getting it out
and that can be like you know
kind of my church my you know having the
conversation or sometimes it comes in
good old-fashioned convulsions of crying
but it's literally that energy flowing
through do you feel the same try to put
fountains and ponds so that it keeps it
clean and keeps it moving and yoga too
right did you start yoga pretty young
how old were you wow you're ahead of the
curve like what year was that yeah
that's about when I started and I blame
Madonna it's like when she had that line
in her son that said I do yoga and
Pilates and the room is full of hotties
and you know I'm satisfied I was like
yeah that's me I want to do that so I
think that was a lot in a song so much
yeah I mean just wasn't very popular
back then
what you wear how do you know what to
wear for your first yoga class for
chores butts stretch not much did you
tell her to go - yeah oh she just gets
to be fit she's one of those she's a
unicorn what did you feel how did you so
ahead of the curve yoga marijuana all
that stuff is everywhere now just ahead
of the curve no that's all I've I've
tried to - for me I just want to go to
sleep so you had like a like a like a
body high relax
she fastens never long enough is it
never long enough do you do so how often
do you do yoga now is it like a do you
practice by yourself or do you go
somewhere is it towards I don't know is
it like a nice it's a longer slower but
but it's very different it's you know
language what's it called again practice
in the States
I almost did a teacher training in
August but it's um it didn't work out
but I would love to do that yeah so um
you know a big part of yoga is like I
feel like you get introduced to a like a
meditation meditation practice and you
know it's what I'm saying like shavasana
ever long enough because you lay there
and you're like I'm just doing my
checklist in my head
I'm like so I have to do this or Orca
had that class and this guy smells
nothing and but I feel like it's hard
for me to get anywhere good in the five
minutes that you're laying there so but
I I personally I really love meditation
I don't do it nearly enough sometimes
I'll be good and it'll be a few days in
a row and then it'll be a couple of
weeks before I do it again and it's but
it's always one of those things that I'm
like yoga and meditation are two things
that I go why don't I do this more often
but my Aries Aries sides of me tell me
go go go go go go and you're moving too
slow which is why of course the
astrologer always tells me to slow down
and sometimes I listen but I really
enjoy it and for me meditation is one of
those things where I energetically reset
to a slower place to a more patient
place to a more open place and I get
messages sometimes I mean it's not every
time but sometimes you I'm hearing like
a repeated phrase like that's meaningful
to me or or I might be might sort of
start to see visions like of certain
images even been able to do telepathy
which is really interesting but
meditation is a great do you do have a
practice of that yeah every day you're
my guru then really what kind of what
does that mean you you feel it what's
the what's the off like for you
and didn't have that how long do I think
that's what discourages me almost from
doing it is I I literally think to
myself I can't get where I need to go
where I've been before in ten minutes or
five minutes so I'm just not gonna do it
at all but like you said even if you
don't get somewhere just breathing just
stopping setting an intention changing
your perspective being grateful is
already changing you I mean you can
change yourself with one deep breath so
why the hell am I so stubborn because
I'm an Aries come in there does this
Emory have that same your wife Emory
does she really yes well it's more
consistent than everyday
yeah like intensional time versus says
it a morning thing everybody has
probably their time or it's like before
I get about her in the morning but well
it's pretty tough to you're like hi
meditating for an hour I know that
there's a meant to be a concert going on
and I think I'm important but but so's
my shows my practice yeah that that
would be tough I mean how does the trap
I mean do you love the travel
I think traveling just in a powder but I
think when you travel it really you know
you just truly have to like as
appreciated sounds like just try to like
kind of like things with my head I go on
when I do this everyday or I'm gonna
like you know make sure I like go here
when I get to that place do you not like
to plan or is it a practice for you to
let go
I mean I agree the travel I've done I'm
like everybody's kind
everybody wants joy and happiness and
peace and there's just a few bad apples
here and there and I don't know where
they are but who's the day right because
I'm not really drawing a line I feel
like because I'm when I when I go there
I'm like oh you're wonderful or you know
meet these other people from other
cultures or other countries or you know
all the things that are meant to divide
us and like I don't really get it like
who's drawing those lines though we need
them gone people's drawing
but if you feel it is talking soft yeah
it's the same thing if you're in another
country you don't even know the person
touch you in some way there's there's
some neurological expert talking about
the brain and talking about energy and
frequency and he's like his name is
Bruce Lipton he said this he's like the
Gazelle does not need to check with the
lion that it wants to eat it it just
knows because of energy right so you can
feel it and so I wonder so I can totally
feel all your loving all the songs then
because I'm I would love to know how it
works how you how a person gravitates
towards a certain artist or a certain
genre because like growing up there's
like I remember one of my best friends
like loved Smashing Pumpkins and I just
didn't get it
they're fine they're fine but I didn't
have their rap you know I have their
albums I didn't put him on my playlist
like but they're fine I mean I
gravitated towards other kinds of music
and I loved it you know she couldn't
figure that out either so it came to me
long long time going like there must be
an energy or a frequency or what I
thought was there must be some vibration
frequency within a song that resonates
with you that was my like thought but
you probably you probably have a better
explanation that's put a lot more
Rochester smile I'm stars everywhere
else of this thinking so much but when I
play music and I bought up listening to
music a connection I don't get your visa
the driver
I want me to like you know one of my 53
allergies this creates pain in da second
when you come to this you come to this
nebula relativity some sweetness of the
mango what why why do you need trees are
[Music]
definitely drop you just so with music
it's that thing where I don't need to
know how it works
I don't care because it's it's going
into my heart and I think that's one of
the in my opinion one of the problems I
think with Western culture is we want an
answer for everything water answers
absolutely other things that we can't
explain
we pushed away because thanks Paris
because training control them that's
just yeah feel like when we can explain
things but the things that we can't
understand
affect our hearts we try which reminds
me of uh movie contact with the Jodie
Foster Matthew McConaughey contact
that's where about are you okay great
well this one's about this one's an old
one and it's and it's about making she
Jodie Foster grows up wants a telescope
her dad gets her one her dad dies when
she's out looking at her telescope
she's very affected by it and she wants
to make connection with anything any
life for matters so gets a frequency
follows it has a code then they build
this device to be that the the that the
code gave them was like a schematics so
they build it and it's this trillion
multi-trillion dollar investment it's a
worldwide thing happening and so they
have like a panel of people you know
weighing in on it and then they need to
figure out who's going to be the one to
go into this device and go somewhere
they don't even know what's gonna happen
they might die and Matthew McConaughey
is his religious he's I'm gonna guess
he's Christian or something and so he he
comes in as sort of like the religious
arm of the group to choose who's gonna
go in this ball and transcend somewhere
or nowhere or die
and so she bases everything she does on
science and he's all you know heart and
spirit and so fast forward to the end of
the movie and she's being slowly
convinced to trust spirit trust feeling
and not so much the science because he
asks her he says let me ask you a
question did you love your dad and she
said of course
and he goes prove it
there's no science to prove it but you
sure as hell can feel it but of course
all those things that we don't really we
can't see and we can't prove we run away
from because we don't understand and I
agree with that I agree with that you've
uh you've gone to India many times what
is it what is it like over there you've
been to ashrams and you know tell me
about what you've done over there I only
really I'm like literally just like I
know you've been to India and I know
you've been ashrams
and it's a yearly thing right yeah yeah
privat can't it just felt like you know
please yeah it just went when I started
going over there in my way it's just the
place where it's stimulation I wonder if
they kind of resonate and a different
like there's the sleep states or and
there's awake and sleep states it's like
Beta Alpha Delta Theta and so like betas
where we like we're in beta right now
and then the next step down which is
alpha that's kind of you're a very
productive space for spirituality I
think then Delta is sleep state theta is
like did the deep sleep I could be
getting some of that wrong but from my
memory that's what it is but Alpha is
very like that's when you meditate when
you slow down so I wonder if they but so
the higher the higher vibration is a low
frequency that makes sense like the
coz-theta is like but the beta is much
faster so alpha is slowing it down so
you talk about the wave like I wonder if
they like resonate and this alpha wave
vibration instead of this beta wave
that's very like you know there's a
little it feels frantic they have their
own wave in India India so do you
are you someone that believes there's
spirituality and then religious like
you're either religious or spiritual
thank you a calling how did you be how
did you get introduced from a saint from
India while you learn
okay oh you call your call your grip the
villagers okay creepy like almost you're
like whoa why why am I so connected to
this photo of this man yeah
st. Teresa say st. Francis of Assisi to
energy so because
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it wasn't the religion that drew on
a throne right so the question that
really kind of sent me there was like
the first way of maybe five years ago
really getting curious about things in
spirituality and meditation and you know
special places it kind of actually all
started in Sedona all in Sedona it
always starts in Sedona with that damn
girl who said you're a celebrity and I'm
like oh my god how do you know this
stuff and I try how do you know this
stuff yep and it kind of started it
started there with some of that exposure
and then a few years ago it's the next
level came from starting to question the
foundations of very simple things so the
question I started asking everybody is
so many people got it wrong they didn't
listen to the first word what is God the
answer by who they're like well he's a
bla bla bla bla so what that that was my
that was a real launching question for
me into the world of questioning
everything really because right when you
start questioning what is God that's a
pretty big question what does God do you
yeah oh well do you talk to him out
what is God to use that's okay you know
even you know just you know they have
amazed is really fun definable table
that yeah - simple not that's done money
was right but they said it that fun work
should be described
that's just yeah but they're asking yeah
like I said the nearest thing you can
even comprehend how close to this to
like speed through our eyes
yeah well I think that we try and put it
into human terms where again we're
trying to we're trying to like put a
label on something we're trying to draw
a picture we're trying to literally draw
a picture and so many people you know
they tried to describe like what is God
but I'm like or who is God but I'm like
not how what is God so you know cuz for
me it's like an omnipresent energy like
it's everywhere and everything and it's
and it's a vibration that's accessible
maybe not by everyone and maybe not
nearly maybe not very often but it's
like a frequency for me it's like a the
highest vibration possible it's that
love frequency or you know those moments
where it's like unexplainable some wave
right I think that I do think it was so
great though how you you you know you
talked about like not needing to explain
just enjoy the wine just enjoy the song
just enjoy it everybody who wants a
simple answer or everybody wants a
everybody wants an answer they have an
idea of the of what they want to hear
and they want they think things should
be complicated they almost are angry
when things are so simple right like
just let it go it's not that big of a
deal it's just life that's my saying
things get tough like it's just life so
speaking of like kind of simple maybe is
you know I you came out with your latest
album the fruitful darkness
last year 2018 yeah I think it was like
the beginning maybe but you kind of you
instead of like this big production of
the album and everything huh you like
just released a few songs at a time
which man for someone who puts their
heart and soul into every song how smart
like I mean because people are gonna
listen
all of those songs all three or four
that I think that's about how you
release em three or four at a time and
because you you you want all of them to
you heard not just like title track or
just like the one that catches on you're
like let them sit because I'm gonna tell
you like when I first listened to each
grouping of songs there was some they
were like okay and then the more you
listen to them the more they like
started resonating with you and you're
like wow and so that's really cool I how
did you even come up with that that way
of doing it simplify things but the main
thing was oh I wanted the whole damn
elbow and I was like really
three songs really yeah yeah it's kind
of pretended as you know in your plan
because some kind of take over and they
want that to act I wanted each talk to
really get proper kind of chance
yeah and so we wanted to release it for
that and we also want that when you
release an album you know your heart
talked about it all year then yes but
you know that takes some bravery because
you had you believe that all of those
songs it every time you came out with
three or four songs four times it was
like you did it quarterly right you had
to believe that those songs would stand
up and and be and be and be something
that would makes people want to listen
to the next group that you released
which you know maybe other maybe I mean
it's a revolutionary way of doing it I
thought it was really cool in the end I
thought it was a really smart thing to
do I of course wanted the whole damn
album like I said but but but and more
the special stuff that you've never
sound for anyone that stuff too but but
it it was a very thoughtful way of doing
it and I would imagine that there might
not maybe it maybe every artist couldn't
do that though do you know what I mean
like maybe they do artists put fluff in
their album what does ep stand for I'm
like what's an EP okay well you came out
with some mini piece I don't know what
it doesn't matter I just listened to the
damn music gosh I said I'd be so
complicated everybody so well you know
like one more dive on like something
sort of serious it was like what was me
it's called fruitful darkness your songs
have intention I would imagine your
title of your album has in ten
so what is the story behind not just how
you named it but what was your darkness
like that's that's what I'm more curious
about ten like I'm Barbara Walters and
I'm like you know you're just sharing
with the Queen and you know this is and
you're ready to share and it can be a
time of like struggle over time so my
darkness tough question still tough
question very tough because there's so
much stimulus I'll take that cuz there's
plenty of disadvantages just ask anyone
I know anyone that knows me because for
somebody like myself
[Music]
protect your energy is it would be
called yeah for those who kind of
started seeking you know it's a question
that can't be this is the difference
between look like when you start to seek
and want truth and you wake up and you
want to know the truth and you're ready
to ask those questions you dive into a
lot of darkness and I think that as a as
a spiritual person as a seeker of truth
it's so much [ __ ] harder now than it
used to be like there is so much more
struggle
there's so much more crying there's so
much more you know evaluating the
situation but finally looking at myself
going is this me because and before that
you don't you blame everyone else and
it's everyone else's problem and
everyone else is doing things to you and
life is happening to you and then when
you become for me this is my experience
more spiritual you become to be quite
honest the more difficult it becomes I
really believe life life is challenging
but damn it it's so rewarding when you
come through the other side and so the
only way to the other side is through
and I say that and I've said that in
difficult times in my life because you
want to avoid it like there's been times
where I've said when things are really
difficult I just wanna go to an island
for a few months and just like check out
and just come back and everything is
fine and I'm where I'm gonna be but you
have to go through the darkness you have
to leave it's it's but look once the
spiritual journey begins and I know many
many people on it you probably know many
many people on it you never leave once
you've begun the journey yeah I mean I
had like you know I I mean one really
amazing experience I had it was in Tulum
Mexico have you ever been there
powerful spot so I went with my
girlfriend who's coming to the concert
and she she and I were there for a week
and we had was probably everything was
day four and we went and did a
three-and-a-half hour yoga class and
then we had a chakra balancing massage
afterwards that we were really late for
so we were hurrying
I'm starving because I have to eat every
three hours so we ride back uptown to
roll up and go get our smoothie bowl
that I had my heart set on because I'm
an Aries and things have to go the way I
want them to go and so I get there and
have the smoothie bowl and you know my
friend Stacy is like buzzing she is like
vibrating and annoying and I'm like why
are you so happy like I'm angry at her
happy
and she's just like so she's just in
this space so we ride back down to the
hotel and I'm like I'm gonna go find a
spot on the beach there's a little Sun
left probably and and she was on the
phone with her husband so I'm like you
know meet you down there I'll be over on
the right-hand side I get down there
there's no Sun and then I kind of move
over still no Sun I end up back at the
original bed that we've been laying on
all week and there's been this dog all
week that I've said I think I'm this dog
I named the dog on the first day and
this and the dog was magical and at any
time I sought this dog out it was never
there but if I let go and didn't care
but truly didn't care like I'm okay all
of a sudden had show up it was the super
weird energetic dog that I named Lucy
and so I go to this spot and all the
sudden dog jumps up and I start bawling
and I have this experience for sorry
I've skipped the part that was really
important before the bawling I I
transported somewhere else for I don't
know how long 15 seconds maybe but I got
this connection with what to me felt
like more of that higher frequency that
love that God vibration whatever it is
where I had this connection to
information that was you are loved
you're always loved no matter what I
love you no matter how far you go I'm
always here it's all there is and I was
like and I just started I just lost it
for like an hour and she came down and
she was like and I see I had just gotten
my [ __ ] together and I'm laying on this
bed and then she comes over and I'm like
and she goes is everything okay
she's like oh and she holds space like
nobody else like she holds space for you
energetically to feel what you're
feeling with no judgment and so I just
lost it but it was like I start I've
been starting to be able to get these
glimpses into this other world other
realm other dimensions that for me
only come when you are you know sort of
on this spiritual journey you have these
or maybe it helps me recognize them but
it was like one of those experiences
that I was like you can never leave this
path like you can't because if you don't
follow your intuition you don't feel
those things why would a I mean how does
a dog facilitate that to happen other
than feeling your intuition and fearing
feeling spirit feeling energy so anyway
I just felt like I had to tell that
story but it was like it was very
powerful have you ever had sort of you
call that it was just all jerseys and my
grandparents moved out a Florida and
your old age and my grandfather my dad
connection my grandfather the whole
thing so my grandfather passes away and
I have this urge to yeah cuz you know
just called up my monk friends I
[Music]
I do a lot of stuff for this I had to
like find means of my grandparents going
back three generations yeah yeah of
course yeah in India that's serious
having been there so the next morning
building this up forever you're ready
it's about me sure I've never been there
we get in the boat and we started
ceremony but the priest he does this
every day this is his job he's out there
every day on the people
come out there to pay a producer so he's
doing this we see Sandy's mantras so
fast and I feel like slow robotic here
like where's the soul mm-hmm and in the
ceremony he's asking me to repeat the
mantras like it's not gonna work not
connected yeah yeah you're not you're
not floating yet ceremony gets done and
I'm like it didn't work
that sucks like this is real shitty I
like I flew halfway around the world I
was so bad we get back in the boat we
get back to the store and we're walking
back to the ashram with these two months
and I'm just pissed I'm just like this
is not a bid and we before we get to the
ashram we stop at this giant stand where
we take Gees right and sit in the choice
ball and I'm so upset that I can't even
be around everybody like to say so I
like walk to the corner corner but its
busiest you know causa you rich off some
cars at dusk the whole thing and I'm
standing on this corner and I start to
like get a little emotional time right
didn't work like I came all this way and
this just sucks
and at that moment a rickshaw pulls up
right in front of you like where you are
late and it stops and there's like a
family like five or six people you know
this Indian family and we're getting out
of the rickshaw and this kid gets out of
the richest all right in front of me and
you're gone oh wow I was gonna say the
grandpa your grandfather got out basic
basically and it was a huge sign you're
like how would that even like no one has
that in the middle of nowhere India did
you have like a big wave come over you
when you saw him you just heart knew it
all yeah it's almost undescribable
yeah yeah although I actually kind of
know that if I seek it I won't get it so
that's pretty tough though because I
really seek that feeling again like
that's like a really it and it was that
day for sure I think that's the thing
that's the thing I think I feel about in
yoga is the is the difference between
trying harder like it's an effort right
spirituality is an effort it's an effort
to face your fears it's an effort to
face the darkness it's an effort to
change your practices whatever they may
be that put you into a good or bad state
your thoughts it's it's it's difficult
but yet it's there's also this other
side and so you have to try there's this
other side where when you finally just
kind of let go let go of control let go
your plans let go thinks all the sudden
the the puzzle starts fitting together
perfect and you're like why do I make
this so hard so that's to me like the
yoga analogy is like the difference
between like trying come on you got to
go go go and then as soon as you and
then you're like oh my god there's my
foot oh my god which by the way my feet
touch my head oh my god I've dreamt
about that I just okay um so I do want
to cover one more thing before we before
I ask you to jam out and this just
because like being in a relationship or
your boat where with someone spiritual
it's somewhat more complicated and
somewhat easier so both being spiritual
people like tell me that yes you and
Emory like how does it look how does an
argument look with two spiritual people
[Laughter]
it's like I think it gives you the your
height the highest of the highs because
I feel like when you are doubting
everything just share this you have that
connection yeah yeah I could just know
you just yeah yeah yeah we're being held
by something yeah
on the other hand right when you're
walking a spiritual path I don't know
what you mean and it usually comes out
all over them and you're like I'm so
projecting right now I'm sorry like I'm
trying to heal an old wound well that's
the first thing that happens you don't
say you just project and then you look
at yourself and go [ __ ] exactly yeah
there yeah people are changing so much
then a relationship I feel like you're
either growing together which is what
the goal that's what you need or you're
growing apart or one's growing and one's
not to me that's like my generalized
view of relationships and so you know
you growing together when you when you
have when you're only about you know how
old Regas early twenties yeah
a lot of growing to do it's a lot of
time to stay on the same page that's a
lot of time to stay connected that's a
lot of time to to grow that you you
really like hoping it's in the same
direction you want it but it can be can
be challenging
you
[Music]
you